all right yo man bootleg podcast
uh extremely honored to be joined by the
homie benny the butcher and his crew now
uh
i'ma let you introduce the squad because
you guys got a gangster grills coming
out
on the 31st that's a fact you know i
mean
uh everybody know what drama bring to
the table it's that street [ __ ] we back
to the streets and i'm saying waking the
streets up again i got my boy
right here you know humor the steamer
rick high right here you know what i
mean
these boys is dangerous so um
benny let me ask you because like i i've
all your fans know except for black
soprano family right
i feel like there's a lot of people who
follow you
who exclusively um connect you with
zelda there's like generic hip-hop fans
who like obviously you're griselda right
right right right so kind of tell us
what what
bsf is about and you know anytime i've
ever seen you i've seen these guys with
you
right this is not new this is and this
is something you've been you know this
is this has been your
imprint your thing for a minute but kind
of break down the
you know kind of the history of bsf uh
basically man
i started uh bsf when i was in
elmira correctional facility reception
you know what i'm saying i was
on my way to do a parole violation and i
just was ready for a change
from when i got back home so i started
in reception as soon as i got there
right we've been working me and rick you
know what i'm saying got out to the
plates
played [ __ ] you know what i mean shout
out ricky not been doing this and i'm
saying even before all that you know i'm
saying
from the hood so it's like when i came
home
it was like a resurgence of what we was
doing and uh i was taking everything way
more serious i was putting way more time
into it even i was going to
put a lot of time in it before it's like
i i felt that i needed i needed an extra
flame underneath so it was basically
like i remodeled the house and uh
rick you know i mean rick always been
right here since day one since he was
cause he was a younger since i was a
younger
and it's crazy because he he always been
from the hood but when he was when he
was serious about rapping two years ago
he came and he paid me for a feature
right
and that's when i was that's when i was
probably like getting a thousand for
first but i'm like i only want to take
the money from him
that's my boy but i know what he wanted
he trying to get is he trying to get his
[ __ ] together but
after that i'm like nah man you you just
if you're gonna do it you're gonna come
[ __ ] with us and do it you know i mean
so
yo on um the uh
butcher meets leatherface joint it
sounded like
rj payne was saying he was on the squad
and then i and then he had hit me and
was like yo i'm excited because i think
i might do something with benny
um you got the deal over at e1
so salute to you that's a big boss move
you've got your label deal over at e1
um shout out to al and everybody over
there but um what what ended up
happening with the rj payne thing
uh basically shout out to payne and
everything but
i guess you know what i'm saying he he i
guess he wasn't ready to make that move
i guess he wanted to just to stay over
there and do what he wanted to do with
his
but his own thing and it's all love to
him you know what i'm saying but that's
just basically what it is you know this
business so sometimes everybody
everybody ain't on the same page you
know what i'm saying but we could we
could
that don't that don't like hurt no
relationship with them right everybody
yeah i wish everybody the best
and i'm saying but we we're moving and
we're working and we're moving forward
so let me ask you this with this
gangster grilled [ __ ]
now obviously we came up man loving
gangster grills
you know dedication the jeezy [ __ ] i
mean everything um
a lot of that [ __ ] isn't on the
streaming platforms it's on that piff
you know
and i'm assuming that this is going to
be on the streaming platforms
correct so this is going to be all
original music
yes sir fire was that like something
because you know
when you it's is with the traditional
gangster grill [ __ ] like you want to
maybe hop on some other beats like
right right right right you know how the
game your game so
finicky right now and uh you know i mean
with the beats and [ __ ] like that and
plus we just wanted to
this this project was mainly the the
jump start everything that we got going
on with e1
run the table with this [ __ ] too i
promise watch this but it's like okay
first thing we do is tap in back to the
streets and go get drama
go get these grimy beats and tapping
back to the streets and
and like you said that [ __ ] wasn't on
streaming that [ __ ] that we do don't be
on streaming platforms
it's on that path you know what i mean
you know if you ever be but we bringing
this [ __ ] back to the forefront i kind
of feel like
yeah i feel like too it's almost like
you gotta like anything you do
like you know everything changes the
mixtape game has changed like you got to
make sure you get your bread off it you
know what i'm saying
and like i said the whole drama [ __ ] was
just to showcase people what we got and
what type of
type of wavelength we on and and using
original beats with dj shea you know i'm
saying he produced
damn near half the thing uh cannon
produced something on there true produce
something on there just like showcasing
our producers too
yeah listen man you guys got man
all of y'all griselda yeah you guys got
some amazing in-house production man
yes we do man yes we do and that's like
the cornerstone other [ __ ]
yo so i've been seeing the way you've
been talking online benny and i've
i i see eye to eye with you and that is
essentially
for the last two years right 2018 2019
you dropped projects that were in
the discussion for best projects of the
year classics right so like
back to back years and you've been
kind of quiet this year i mean outside
of touring
and doing all the griselda [ __ ] and
hopping on and just bodying everybody's
albums that's not your own [ __ ]
um but i've been seeing you talking that
talk like listen once the
once the floodgates open up i'm about to
take this whole this year is mine
yeah yeah cause i'm about to open them
up and what i've been doing is
i'm just at the chessboard and and and
i'm looking for a checkmate
i found it you know what i'm saying
though i could take pieces and all that
i've been setting up a checkmate and
from
july 31st mark my words from july 31st
when uh respected sopranos come out dj
drama
black soprano family from that day to
the end of the year i'm taking over
for the past three straight years all my
all my albums been
in the top 10 of the year for sure i've
been having versus top 10 complex
for the past three years you know what
i'm saying so it's nothing going to stop
it's just i've been elevating and i've
been lining up my moves
yo i saw you better than the next one i
saw you tweeted yesterday that
you're gonna do tana talk four and five
together
yeah yeah double album yeah yeah and i
want none of you rap [ __ ] to steal my
idea either
you what i'm saying i'm gonna do tender
talk four and five that's gonna be a
double album
double album i'm assuming you're sitting
on so much music bro
if you know and one thing about me if i
if me benny the butcher haven't dropped
in 14 months you know what i got i got
that that's what i'm saying
fault of [ __ ] cause your squad like you
know the griselda team man you guys put
out
music at it at a at a high rate
actually i would say this i like i like
the way that you drop
projects because i it feels like you
like you said like tana talk three was
i mean flawless just rap music plugs i
met
but it but the squad like yo man we got
so much you know just
amazing music coming from like if you're
not dropping
guns dropping conway's dropping exactly
and i'm on all their projects so
that's kind of feel like people will be
a little appetizer you know like
to keep your fans people been starving
for that solo project but you know what
i'm saying i've been all over the place
i'm in
a little wayne album this year uh
this is about to come out russ
uh gibbs yo the gibbs [ __ ] is crazy
yeah so i'm still working hey talk about
um
because you were supposed to go on tour
with russ and
russ is one of those guys that like i
feel like
he gets he gets some some negative
feedback because i feel like people
think he's a little arrogant but i
i take it the other way i take it like
yo this guy's
he kind of knows what he's talking about
and i always noticed
that he reaches out to artists it
doesn't matter necessarily because he's
you know he's a big artist
but he just reaches out to artists that
he [ __ ] with that he's a fan of no
matter
what the case is and when i saw him put
you on his album
this was at the beginning of the year um
and then put you on the road with him i
was like that's so
dope like because that's gonna bring
your movement to so many
random kids who never heard of you talk
about you and russ's relationship
can't nobody tell me [ __ ] about russ you
know what i'm saying
okay nobody tell me [ __ ] about russ just
you said it
you didn't have to do none of that and
you know what i mean and me i'm a
i'm a street [ __ ] so when you do things
like that
for me that calls for uh
for loyalty you for what i'm saying
because he didn't have to do that so i
only know how to
i only know how to like react to certain
[ __ ] like that in certain ways like
keep putting food on the table for my
family he providing opportunities for me
and my [ __ ] right here so me being
from where i'm from like that calls for
loyalty you can't you think tell me [ __ ]
about russ man he a good dude
i want to ask the squad like because i i
think back
back in the day when uh when the g unit
tapes were happening
and and now you're a superior rapper to
50 cent benny i i don't know if you know
that or not
lyrically lyrically listen 50's got all
the hits but what i'm
what what i was trying to get to was you
remember when 50 dropped
i mean 50 had the melodies like 50 could
rap obviously but
but then there was like lloyd banks
right and you'd be like damn
banks is is iller than
50. like are you are you two
obviously man you guys got one of the
top five right now
running running the point right now you
know me and fred had this conversation
like
there's five guys right now and benny is
one of the five
of the jedis but do you do you guys take
this as a challenge to kind of
stand out and out rap your boss on this
project
man like every chance i get to rap next
to this dude i
is i go with that mentality because you
got to
because yeah he gonna bring it all and i
feel like he
i feel like benny when i would watch all
them freestyles
2016 20 like on static show
and it was about gun and conway but you
would get the mic i feel like oh
my you you took that and you ran with it
like are you guys kind of doing that
same [ __ ]
yeah hell yeah man it's just always been
like that since like like
bro said i've been around him since
forever it's always been like that
though
and you got to appreciate that because
that's it's friendly competition and he
do it too
right he do it too he do it the most
right you do it the most so so you gotta
go in with that mentality because you
know he coming to kill him he just
texted us in the group message the other
day like i'm about to smoke young
man i do that i do that so they can try
to smoke me
because even trust me even even
even our favorite rappers who we love
and and love to listen to
they do the same thing with me i got
songs with some [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] be
trying to smoke my boots
that make your best work exactly you
know i make your best work though
depression
benny uh you like you said you've been
on songs with
i mean some of the greatest right black
thought uh push
like um what was the one verse that you
got back
well first of all i don't take you as
the kind of guy who would go in and
change a verse after you got another
verse back am i right on that
never never never right so that's fair
so what is a verse that you got back if
ever
where you were like all right man my guy
my guy got me on this one
has that ever happened let me see
last uh never
that's fair that's fair never
um that's just my opinion people might
have a different opinion but no i
actually concur with you i've never
heard you get like i've never heard a
record where
i've been like yeah benny got got on
i've told freddy gibbs he's gotten got
on records
and he got really pissed at me yeah he
had a song with black thought called
extradite and i was like fam how are you
gonna let black thought eat your
eat you up like that on a song
and he just knocked like freddie man
yeah you guys look like you were out
there
you guys look like you were
participating in a lot of [ __ ] out
there in miami
no i never said this publicly yeah i
never said this publicly
but when when thought was sending me the
record back
he was like yo i'm about to send the
record back and i'm like oh and i'm
realizing okay you have a record with
black thought that's going to eventually
come out
i'm thinking like did i bite off more
than i could choose you know what i'm
saying
i did think about that you know what i
mean shout out to thought and that's
what i love i love sparring with the
best before
he's one of them ones man exactly i love
sparring with the best and sometimes
i might even just reach out to do a
track with a dude just to measure myself
to see you know what i'm saying
i'm like oh okay yeah i'm up there yeah
when it comes when it comes to the
like the jedi like first of all i wanna
i wanna commend you guys
um because i do feel like
you know i've been a fan of you guys
since the first time i think i saw y'all
on
static [ __ ] which was four or five for
you
i think five years ago i don't know um
but uh
i remember like just the way you guys
the fly [ __ ] the the merch the branding
like
everything was so raw and i just
remember always being like man this is
the [ __ ] that's missing right like
i i want to give you guys a lot of
credit because
you you know gibbs uh
royce you know uh run the jewels like
it's it's becoming um okay
and and and actually becoming like
better
to have integrity on the microphone
in 2020 and you know two years ago even
when when you and i first met you know i
was already
super tapped in and a big fan but we had
never met before but that was 2018 when
we when we first came on the station and
uh
and you know that there was that was a
rough time for rap man because it was
the all-time high for this instagram
clout
[ __ ] people doing all kind of weirdo
[ __ ] on the internet
and and little pump getting signed and
all these [ __ ] weirdos who ain't
around no more
and you guys continuing to push your
line
and not switching up has helped like
shift the momentum in hip-hop to where
it should be like
it's almost like like i called you y'all
jedi's right but it's almost like
like the force is like on the good side
now like the dark
like like the force was dark for a
little bit you know what i'm saying the
evil empire has the [ __ ] for a while but
i think
because of what y'all have done it's
like yo man like
you guys are going to be able to exist
forever
which is something that is you guys are
making timeless music
and yeah and and and you're making it
dope to be a real emcee again like
and and i just want to commend y'all for
that because you guys you know are a
large part as to why that is
going on right now you know what i'm
saying like so salute man
it's like it feel good to feed the
culture and and i know i'm a rapper i
tap
in with these dudes it's a relief for
everybody too it's a relief
for our genre of music and it's good to
receive our flowers that we put in this
this type of effort and this type of
work and uh
to get fans the art the art in the most
beautifulest form you know i'm saying it
feel good
to get our praises and and for this
business to be lucrative because
like you said they had that they had
they try to ain't nothing wrong with the
other music i listen to that [ __ ] all
the time but
no there's like some good [ __ ] that's on
the other spectrum right like i [ __ ]
with little baby i [ __ ] with but i'm
talking like i'm talking the weirdo
there was like a weirdo [ __ ] moving yeah
was a part of it lil pump like all these
weird like
he's youtubing at like these guys who
would worry about
their instagram stunt going viral as
opposed to their song being good
and getting deals like like that was a
real there was a moment in hip-hop for
about two years and it was like
it was terrible bro and me in the
meanwhile y'all were doing y'all's
thing but nobody at the time who wasn't
you know obviously you guys had fans i
was one of them but i just remember i
would big y'all up in every interview to
every rapper that would come through
they're like who's griselda who's
griselda like who is she and i'm like no
it's not a she's a [ __ ] label bro
like
you know i mean but but i do i just want
to give you props man cause because
between you and and conway and gunn like
you guys really have helped
fix hip-hop like you know i said i got
to give props to gibbs i got to give
props to uh
to royce i got to get props to run the
jewels um but it's definitely man it's
just refreshing that
finally you guys are getting that uh
acknowledgement
i mean obviously m tapped in super early
too you know what i mean so shout out to
em
um but yeah i just want to give you
props man um
when it comes to uh listen tell me about
your relationship with drake benny
oh man drake cool man drake cool when he
hit me up he always hit me up
in the studio he'd be late in the studio
about 3 4 in the morning you know what
i'm saying he always hit me up when he
on his creative [ __ ]
and what i'm saying just a regular
relationship you know what i'm saying he
takes
i'll text him is there going to be a
drake record
huh drake record you want to hit right
you got it want me to play it play it
nah just [ __ ] wish
you got it of course of course so
there's a drake feature
yeah yeah yeah is that for your project
is that for tana talk or is that for his
[ __ ]
uh actually he sent me a verse and i
sent him a verse so if he used the one i
sent him then you know what i'm saying
hopefully yo i think uh
man i'm excited right right now another
person who didn't have to reach out to
me or mention my name and nothing like
that you know what i'm saying
and drake's the jedi for the record
drake is a jedi drake
that's a humble one and
here type of person who who done favors
with people and you know i mean people
still throwing shade
he talked about it in songs all the time
and i wondered about him you know i'm
saying a person who
would get on people's songs and he's one
of the biggest artists and do people
favors and people still try to slight
him and shade him
like that's crazy for him to still be
enthusiastic about other artists and
still do it
you know what i mean so shout out to
drake 100 now um
okay so plugs i met two is that gonna be
with harry fraud all hairy frog all
hairy frog
paul harry fraud yup yup now
give me the timeline we know july 31st
we're getting the gangster girl
the boy talk about this uh [ __ ]
july 30 i was waiting
july 31st we got the respective sopranos
with these guys
yep what i'm saying and they going crazy
they bombing on this [ __ ]
and we got jonesy on there we got lovey
on there we got the rest of the black
sopranos on there it's crazy
uh september september this is the big
one right here september
we got burton of proof you know what i'm
saying produce
whole solely by hit boy oh by the way
i've heard
i was in the studio and i've been in
with hit and he's played me all y'all
[ __ ]
and it is yo you guys got hit boy in his
boombap bag something crazy
definitely legend has it legend has it
that that this album is perfect
you for what i'm saying no fam i heard i
heard a lot of it and there's some
there's some there's some nice little
features on there right
yes sir yes sir so so you know what i
mean that's that's my next attempt
that's what the streets been waiting for
that's going to be the next official
release from benny you and hit boy
now wait benny benny did you did you get
sean on the project
big sean not yet not yet not yet i
called him the other day like a week ago
like yo bro i need you
he's like just send it but it's about
do i want to use my favor for this
project of course i do or you know what
i mean
i hear you so so you and hit boy so okay
so that's happening in september it's
called burden of proof
burden of proof produced by hitboy man
he gave me he gave me a thousand percent
another person who didn't have to i'm a
lucky [ __ ]
who just didn't have to reach out to me
to work and just it was one of the helps
bro
exactly we put this project together not
knowing it was going to become what it
is today not knowing we was going to
turn down
several million dollar offers for the
project we just in there fighting you
know i'm saying it
and we're still dropping the project
independently this is what we do
all right so that's happening in in
september um
what it what about the the the double
album and and the album with uh with
with harry fraud are we getting both of
those before
january 1st oh not hell no okay okay i'm
just i'm just trying to i'm just trying
to
see the timeline i'm a visionary i'm a
visitor
and i'm saying i'm always moving 10
steps ahead of ahead of [ __ ] because
that's how i got here so really i got
the uh
burden to prove september you know i'm
saying first quarter
or maybe [ __ ] i might even drop at the
end of this year but that's next on the
calendar is
plugs i met two produced by harry frah i
got dope features on there
and then like everybody asked me because
tanner talk three is a work of art
everybody like talk four are coming when
it's gonna talk four coming
i could easily name these projects
tandem talk four and put them out but
yeah
and if the tanner talk series is is
different you know what i'm saying
and i treat it with care and everybody
been waiting for and i said i gotta live
a little bit more life i gotta
and i'm saying things gotta happen in my
life before i feel comfortable calling
another project tana talk
and i feel like i'm at that point now
which project is the drake feature going
to live on
oh man that's a surprise okay hey let me
ask you this because i feel like once uh
plugs on that came out that was kind of
when uh
people were starting to you know get on
the on the griselda bandwagon right
[Music]
i'm i personally i love both projects i
think they're both classics between
tanner talk three and
and and plugs i met but i i i like tan
to talk three more
what do you think what's better
obviously the uh you know plugs i met is
a shorter project
but if you had to pick one uh if i had
to pick one
i would have to pick i would have to
pick over just a slight
slight slight edge i would pick plugs
i'm at
that's here i love tanner talk three
i love that man me that's basically a me
west
derringer conway project because they
assisted with me on that
before what i'm saying and that was my
introduction uh the plugs i met
i followed the formula and i did
everything myself and i was really
testing myself off
and i put that out on my own so you know
it's it's a little bit more
you were more yeah you were
quarterbacking that a lot more exactly
and
and and it turned out to be successful
so incredible follow my face in it put a
little
put i could poke out my chest a little
bit more and what about the bsf boys
what i'm assuming that are we going to
get solo projects
from from either of you guys this year
i'm working on plates too i'm pretty
much wrapped up you know i'm saying i'm
just waiting
on that green light but we good do you
know how many random caucasian people
are going to be like why do you name his
album plates
now
well it's also like where you cut up the
brick right that as well
listen i may or may not have also sold
drugs in my life
and still currently do but now they're
just green you feel me you know some
[ __ ] and he
come up with some [ __ ] we dropping
mixtapes everything like that's the plan
is to
set these boys where they could take
over where where the streets could see
where they coming from and people could
not say understand these boys and and
they pushing they pushing
forward they in the lead for black
soprano family bro
people love him you know what i'm saying
this [ __ ] lyrical ability i could tell
he'd be trying to come for me on song
and i'm saying it's like real [ __ ] hey
let me ask you this
um obviously you're the one guy from
griselda that
that that eminem didn't necessarily
officially sign
why um what is your relationship like
with m because we all know he has to
regret that decision at this point in
time
um like are you guys cool have you guys
ever had that discussion
because like i never i never even i
never like had that discussion with him
i just met him seen him passing you know
what i'm saying
right with that it's like it's really
not a relationship there the respect is
there you know what i'm saying
you know i mean the [ __ ] you to god but
you know what i mean to be honest with
you
as far as me you know what i mean like i
i didn't get a contract oh i
didn't get a contract offer from shady
until everybody was all for me
so everybody was trying to come for you
that's what i assumed yeah yeah you know
what i'm saying until
until you know at a point in time i was
like anxious to sign the shady but
they by the time they came with a
contract offers like everybody was
coming like signing the deal probably
wasn't the smartest thing for me to do
at that point
at that point in time you could have
probably pick and chose whoever you
wanted to go exactly
exactly yeah you know let's shout out to
shady man i love mike you know i'm
saying me and mike we can't get
uh paul rosenberg always been fair to me
before what i'm saying
always been fair to me so let me ask you
this um
it's crazy what because like you said
um you've turned down some million
dollar millions of dollars in record
deals i'm sure right listen
you're and people who don't know this
you've been doing this rap [ __ ] for a
long time
you know what i mean like you're new to
like the the mainstream i guess you
could say
but when it comes to like being in the
industry like y'all have been doing this
forever man so
like you're not gonna jump on a lot of
people jumping on whatever comes their
way
you know what i mean they're gonna jump
on some [ __ ] deals you decided to go
with e1 do the label deal
and and i'm assuming ownership has got
to be a big
a big part of that but like what because
you say i mean i'm assuming everybody
was trying to sign you
um what made you want to go the e1
direction
and not necessarily you know go the
direction of a major because i'm sure
every major was on like trying to tap in
with you
uh everybody asked me that question and
i and the answer is transparency
before i'm saying i don't i can't i
can't be like
label talked all that propaganda none of
that [ __ ] matters to me
the transparency our communication you
know what i'm saying is
who gonna be on these phone calls what
is we doing i can't be i can't be
romanced a couple labels try to romance
me into a contract
of course i want you for what i'm saying
and and let's be real here
a lot of labels just wanted to a couple
labels wanted to take the bsf thing
because
just because of me you from what i'm
saying over at e1
they they concerned about these dudes
and
even at the end of the day at the end of
the day
i could have took it anywhere but i'm
still in these offices
speaking for these [ __ ] so i can't do
what i want to do i got a number
these are my friends before you know i'm
saying music and you want to make sure
they're good
exactly so it's like e1
it was all good and we had it was offers
on the table and that was the best one
and we was and we were surprised i'm not
gonna lie we were surprised we had a
great meeting with them and they
followed through on everything they said
and more so the transparency is the best
thing
i think too what's dope is um you have a
really good example of
how to develop artists and how to
because i truly feel that the the way
gunn has
like i feel like gunn is wants you to be
bigger than him
if that makes sense go ahead
you're right you hit it on you hit it
you hit the target like i learned how to
develop artists a lot from west side gun
and that's what i appreciate [ __ ]
there ain't no secret if you're watching
it if you've seen me what i'm doing
there's not no secret what i'm doing
yeah
all part of the formula i'm never going
to change the formula
you know we all see this [ __ ] happen
like 99
of the time when you are a rapper and
you have artists that you sign
like they never end up surpassing what
you do
and sometimes that's by design because
i've had conversations with people who
they're like yeah like
you know like like it's an ego thing
because
with you know what mc's like it's an ego
driven sport which is why a lot of times
like
you know the exception is when rick ross
signs meek mill
and wales you know what i mean there's
like there are few exceptions though
so i think that what's been dope to
watch the way griselda
moves and the way you guys always
support each other
and the way it's like yo like i said man
like i just remember you know
four or five years ago i was a huge
conway fan
i [ __ ] with conway tough like he's my
favorite dude out of griselda
and then i forget which freestyle it was
i think he was rocking the shady mccoy
and the little
buffalo bills joint and i was like oh my
god
right right right and then i just dived
into your [ __ ]
and you know i just think that it's
important that like
you know if you're gonna like you say
man these guys are your friends and
their
and their livelihood depends on you and
you don't take that lightly
you know what i'm saying real [ __ ] and
you know they trust me so
i value that trust so i know i got to do
the right thing with it you know i'm
saying that
i'm confident in these dudes man listen
i
i got the coronavirus [ __ ] around in
arizona now i saw y'all out in miami
at g5
getting down with the [ __ ] y'all good
did y'all lose your smell
you guys good out there i'm just gonna
make sure y'all good cause i caught this
[ __ ]
you have it straight we straight man we
straight man god blessing us man we
gotta
we gotta move careful we gotta move
smart but man we straight all right so
we got plates two on the way we got
hit boys uh so that's gonna be in
september burden of proof you and hit
boy
um on july 31st you guys went out to
atlanta and we're shooting videos for
this project right i saw you guys was uh
all
all decked out on some dick tracy [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying on my [ __ ] al capone
[ __ ] yeah yeah uh and so that's coming
out july 31st
it's a gangster grills um
who's who can you i mean it's a couple
weeks away now who's on the project
besides the team i'm sure you guys might
might have tapped in with some uh
some outside that's the thing we didn't
because the whole
the whole uh point of this project is
just to showcase us and that's the thing
we coming right back with the
black soprano family compilation you
know that's kev that's why i mean what i
say is like i'm literally about to take
over the rest of the year with this [ __ ]
okay so i didn't know that so there's
gonna be another one yeah
all right cool man well listen um i
appreciate you guys checking in and
and benny man like yo you're
you're that guy bro i want you to know i
i i i before it was cool to do so man
i've been screaming your name at the top
of my lungs
you invited me to the show i'm like oh
[ __ ] me nah but
yeah even before that like when because
i you know every time i talk to artists
i try to i try to like you know who you
listening to that's on the come up and
you know i try to
you know put on put but you are
like you got like i will say this man
it's the jedi club and you're in it and
and i just had a conversation with
somebody the other day and it was like
yo benny loki has an opportunity
to go like go down like legit bro as
like an all-time great
damn i mean that bro like you
you have the capabilities to do so bro
so like that's that's pressure on my on
my shoulder
honestly i feel that and that's why i
haven't dropped the project
in so long because i've been i'm
aligning like i said i'm lining up a
checkmate i promise [ __ ]
i'm lining up a checkmate and i think uh
we put it in order
uh solo fire solos the burton the proof
project with harry
i mean hit boy the plugs i met too with
harry
frog you know what i'm saying and tanner
talk four and five that's a double album
i'm gonna be here for
for another 10 years and i never thought
i'd ever hear a rapper
talk about the coke game as well as
pusha t does but i mean you're up you're
there with him
listen listen i hate the people always
say i glorify this street [ __ ]
i glorify how far we came from it i
really got this hand dirty
i really got these hands dirty was doing
all type of [ __ ] these [ __ ] rap about
it never done
and i did the time for this [ __ ] and i'm
back and i learned so much from that
[ __ ] this business mind just don't come
from
what i'm saying yeah would there ever be
a world in which um
i i i i told this to fred too i was like
yo i want to hear you and benny do a
whole project
just talking about selling cocaine
that'd be amazing i want to do that
that's something that i want to do
in push yeah yeah yeah that's something
i need to do
18 wheeler is like man it's time
man come on man that's a snowstorm
that's crazy
that's one of my all my favorites i
gotta be the name of the project
or the wind stars or some [ __ ] yeah i
mean anyway listen
manny i appreciate you bro july 31st tap
in uh thank you for talking to me man
and um i'm gonna make sure look ricky
i'm gonna send you guys some drugs
you guys are in buffalo right now now we
live in atlanta we're in atlanta oh you
guys live in atlanta
oh [ __ ] hey man much better weather i'm
sure
way better way better hey hey real quick
let's just take it to football before we
wrap this up you guys
what what you want to talk about
no no no listen listen i i don't [ __ ]
with the patriots
at all this might be the year for y'all
to win that finally get that division
title i'm just
i'm a cardinals fan i'm from arizona you
know i got charles barkley dug into
basketball on the subs jersey right
there you know what i'm saying
but yeah yeah y'all feeling good about
the bills this year you know i'm feeling
great i'm a real
buffalo bills fan people see i was at
the
houston playoff game they put the jordan
crying face on my [ __ ]
it is what it is i'm gonna live and die
with my team man shout out my boy dion
shout out everybody cody you know what
i'm saying shout out all my boys
hey what's up with these uh white people
in buffalo that be uh
you know some real white people [ __ ]
going on before the games man jumping
off the trailers and the tables and
i mean y'all got the craziest [ __ ]
tailgate parties i have ever seen is
that just uh
cause cause any [ __ ] to do out there but
get [ __ ] up and go to the games on
sunday like help me understand
ready now we gotta bring you the one you
gotta host one man
y'all play the cardinals we gon turn up
not real [ __ ]
real [ __ ] i'm gonna love to see that one
my guys i'll talk to y'all soon man i
cannot wait to hear the project july
31st make sure y'all send me some clean
music to play too
i love my boy all right geez all right
all right fellas